oh my God I I was telling her I ran cuz
Chelsea we we you and Chelsea you
playing at the Beacon we and I hadn't
seen I had been out that's my first
night out in New York oh really yes and
it was so good like it was it made me
laugh so hard and you just forget like
how much laughing makes you feel good
and just like I it just what you do is
so beautiful for people because we had
been so busy and not had a day off and
Chelsea was like Hey I'm playing here
come see it and I was like okay cool and
then she invited me to the party which I
am not an Afterparty person I was
looking for you at the after party I
know but I was there for a second and
then I I want to say hi to Kell look I'm
going to be honest with you I'm super
old like I'm 80 like I'm literally 80
years old I I love to go home and go to
bed like I've never even in my 20s I've
never been this girl New York's a night
City though not me though yeah yeah I'm
going to enjoy it until about 9 and then
I'm going to start heading home yeah
I've just never been that kid you you
are you like I'll at 4 or 5 in the
morning oh my
God like I'm exhausted at hearing that
information so oh my gosh so what you're
getting married as well soon right yeah
yeah 2024 summer spring summer okay well
those are very different so you should
pick one we're trying to like land on
which one yeah oh my God in that hat I
love a hat I was just saying everybody
looks cooler than a hat I love a hat so
where are you getting married do you
know yet we are thinking about Mar
Vineyard I think that's what weed on
yeah yeah I'm exited more remote I like
that remot pretty yeah yeah I love your
standup with her does she does she mind
like your comedy when you're on stage
sometimes I was like oh my God it's so
funny but you really do talk about what
we really do think about which is why
it's funny yeah I um I try to be
observational in my comedy and like put
it in a place where everyone could
relate to it you know what I mean like
take the mundane and turn it up a little
bit oh my God it so funny do y'all have
any wedding advice she's I'll take some
yeah keep it simple just focus on you
guys like that weddings do get out of
hand they start to be about everybody
else that's how it feels like you're
paying for everyone else to have fun
and your head cut off yeah mine's always
about the reception I don't really enjoy
weddings I'm just being honest but but
the reception is that's where the whole
thing at yeah that's when you drink a
little too much and then people get
really liquid courage and start doing
things that maybe they shouldn't but
it's so fun to watch watch yes it's not
fun when you're that person and you see
the video the next day that was a look
at Sam's new standup special it's called
salute me or shoot me you can see it on
HBO and Mac so I literally I keep I'm
just going to keep bragging about you
you make me laugh so hard so what's
explain this special what's different
about this one uh I think the difference
is I'm just funnier you know like I've
grown I've grown in comedy I'm more com
confident you know I've been doing it
for a while I have the writing
experience of SNL and I went off to do
my own late night show so I'm just
confident I feel like that comes through
I feel funnier you know so I think
that's the biggest difference yeah I
think you've always been funny but yeah
yeah you can feel it though you know
when you're growing in something oh my
God and you're I can't get past like I
enjoy physical comedy as well so like
you could not say anything and even
watching you there like your eyes tell
such a funny story and you haven't even
said words yet it's like it's such
beautiful thing that not everybody has
yeah it's also why I'm bad at poker but
yes I you have no Bluff you're like oh
my
god um so I heard that you have a day to
yourself right from your hometown Sam J
day oh yeah yeah yeah yeah which has a
nice ring Sam J day Sam J day they got M
day in the city of Boston what does this
mean do you get like free stuff on this
day no it actually means uh nothing but
everything you know it's like the city
honoring you and they give you a street
sign like an official street sign that's
cool which is pretty cool but I think
it's mostly what I make of it I'm going
to try to do something in the city on
that day like something for my community
and just try to make every day that you
know every year when that day comes that
I do something yeah for sure just stand
up there just make everyone happy okay
I'm just saying you're so funny do you
have a Billy Ray day there's got to be a
Billy Ray day um I don't think there is
one y we can share
mine we are going to make a Billy Ray
day I'm down with that absolutely I
don't have a day either if it makes you
feel any better I was given a keto a
city once and I was like does it open a
door like what are we doing with yeah no
it's just a plaque with a key on it can
you go to like any restaurant you want
and then like they seat you
automatically no I one it was so funny
actually cuz uh when I was married um
his sister one time we couldn't get into
her she was like oh so you're like a C
Level like you're like you're not a
anymore you're like see and I was like
you're hilarious no no I can't do
anything
cool yeah I think that's what makes us
cool yeah I'm still on Open Table you
know what I mean oh yes I love Open
Table I love it yeah I totally love that
so wait do you have you cuz SNL you've
been at 30 Rock quite a bit so do you
have any advice for me I love the
building the building is dope the whole
underground situation be aware of the
holidays you're going to it's going to
make you hate Christmas no it won't I
promise it won't no it won't I want to
revisit this I have two Christmas albums
I want to revisit this okay cuz that
tree and that traffic and that that gets
crazy I have performed that it several
times I love love Christmas I am the
person that annoys you in your family
you're like oh they're vomiting
Christmas again that's fun like that's
me I have a whole village I set up at my
house all right well maybe you
won't I'm going to make it worse here
like no I love it so much but I I heard
that you use men's restrooms if the
girls you're just like no yeah that's
another thing I was going to tell you
the bathroom on eight is a good place to
poop okay I think that's important when
you work somewhere no you got to know
yeah we actually have it's so hilarious
on our floor there's one single bathroom
that you can use and then there's the
one that you know Community everybody
and it's like the single you know what
everyone's doing when they walk in I
passed by reception I'm like that that's
right yeah Mama's got to go I like when
the stall door goes all the way down to
the feet so people can't see the feet
and they don't know how long you've been
in there yeah I don't like when the feet
are exposed you have a lot of pressure
when you poo okay yeah I'm just like
everybody it I don't care look you
walked in here this is where I'm
supposed to be doing it like true yeah
that's on you I'm going to flush and go
I'm polite I'm polite I have used men's
restrooms though because when you go to
a restaurant and I don't care get mad
about it men but like I I am upset
because there's never a line there
there's never a line yeah and it's
actually kind of clean clean cleaner cuz
you know why every woman walks in
thinking your nail and it there's pee
all over the seat it's like that's it's
not helpful and if you do that you clean
it up ma'am you know what it is though
like like with the squat yeah but what
information isn't out there is that you
got to aim here's the bigger thing so
has anyone tried to go you're welcome
America has anyone like they sell you
Spanx and they're like oh man there's a
hole so it'll make it easier no not
you're so
cool watch out for that bathroom on
eight everybody at 30 rck let's do it I
just love the person that walks in that
doesn't know the Poo bathroom and
they're like
[Music]
[Applause]
ah thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home